last year's refugee crisis hit Europe
hard but can the crisis be resolved in
2016
good de Strasbourg plenary perhaps a
find solutions to the months ahead
it's time to find out welcome to agenda
a new year brings with it a new
presidency as Netherlands takes over the
reins of the EU Council the usual
declarations of live long and prosper
have been made but the Dutch have some
tricky waters to steer top of their
agenda for their six-month 10-year we'll
be getting to grips with a migrant
crisis and whether protecting EU borders
kidman disabling the Schengen Agreement
dutch Prime Minister Mark Rutte a and
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
will be present in the chamber for a
debate with MEP s on Wednesday morning
is Europe headed for democracy crisis as
Poland layers of track an October
election swept the euro skeptic law and
justice party to power who have since
come under fire from Brussels for
introducing laws that threaten
fundamental rights the European
Commission in an unprecedented move has
now launched an inquiry into whether
these new laws break EU democracy rules
if so they could invoke article 7 of the
Lisbon Treaty suspending parents voting
rights in the EU Council now to her own
Parliament she declared that democracy
is alive and well the what will Prime
Minister be after said - I have to say
before any Peas at the chamber in
Strasbourg follow the debate on Tuesday
have you heard about teaser the trade in
services agreement currently under
negotiation that would open up services
to foreign companies the services
agreement has been criticized for
negotiations being shrouded in secrecy
just like TTIP the transatlantic trade
deal but also just like TTIP it would
open foreign markets to European
companies but to get a little you have
to give a little could that mean that
public services are up for grabs
MEP say no what should be the red lines
in Strasbourg the trade committee will
hold an extraordinary meeting to vote on
a set of do's and don'ts to be presented
to negotiators and now for some news in
brief it was a unanimous decision to
hear Frances call for help
following multiple attacks in Paris but
how should Member States contribute to
Frances war on Isis any peace debate the
way ahead with a vote on Thursday
upgrading Europe's digital prowess
hurtles forward as MEP sold their own
non-binding vote on the digital single
market strategy
and they forget to tune in for a key
debate we're both European Council
President Donald Tusk and European
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
will be quizzed by ep's on the European
Council meeting that took place in
mid-december could a new emissions a
testing system for cars that make the
Parliament invoke its right to veto
instead of being tested in the lab car
emissions can now be tested on the road
mep it will environment committee have
called the change unjustified and oppose
it will the full house share their
opinion a debate takes place on monday
and that's all we have this agenda take
care and enjoy the week